♪ ♪ ♪
- Vendredi soir,
parc Jean-Drapeau,
première soirée d'Osheaga.
Dans cette fourgonnette,
un laboratoire mobile
a été aménagé.
ROXANNE HALLAL, Groupe de rech.
et d'interv. psychosociale
- On est ici, parce qu'on va
faire de l'analyse de substance,
juste à l'extérieur des clôtures
de l'événement, pour les gens
qui veulent bien utiliser
ce service.
- Depuis 25 ans, le GRIP
sensibilise et offre de l'aide
aux consommateurs de drogue
en milieu festif. Ce nouveau
service d'analyse est gratuit
et légal.
- Ça, c'est de la coke.
- Judith, nom fictif, est venue
faire analyser ce qu'elle
s'apprête à consommer.
- Pour savoir est-ce qu'on va
même être capable d'en boire.
- Pour... Pour le mettre
dans le spectromètre,
qui est la machine là-bas.
Euh... Ça détecte tout ce qui
est présent dans l'échantillon
à 5 % ou plus.
- Ce nouvel instrument permet
une analyse plus poussée.
Grâce mption de Santé
Canada, le GRIP peut manipuler
et redonner la substance
au consommateur après analyse.
- Fait que, j'ai été capable
de trouver de la cocaïne,
mais aussi quelque chose
qui s'appelle la lidocaïne.
La lidocaïne, c'est un agent
de coupe qui est quand même
fréquent dans la coke.
Puis, dans le fond,
analgésique.
- Un test pour détecter du
fentanyl est aussi effectué.
Il s'avère négatif.
- (Judith): C'est toujours
une inquiétude, parce que
j'ai beaucoup d'amis, en fait,
qui ont eu des problèmes avec
le fentanyl. Donc, je trouve
que ce service-là, c'est quelque
chose qui devrait se faire plus
souvent, parce que, vu que
c'est illégal, les gens,
ils ont peur.
♪ ♪ ♪
MAGALI BOUDON, DG, Groupe de
rech. et d'interv. psychosociale
- En général, si on est présent,
si on offre des seest
parce que la situation existe.
C'est parce que, passage
à l'acte, il y a. Ça ne va pas
créer une augmentation
du passage à l'acte,cte,cte,cte,
ça va éviter qu'une personne
qui passe à l'acte soit seule,
isolée et sans outils.
- Au Québec, six organismesont a
pour effectuer l'analyse
de drogues. Le GRIP souhaitait
depuis lu'un tel
service soit offert dans le
contexte d'événements festifs.
- Et on nce,
particulièrement avec la crise
des surdoses, par exemple,
à un petit peu oublier,
peut-être, cette population
consommatrice. Dans le sens
où c'est tellement récréatif
puis de temps en temps qu'ilssot
de ce qu'il se passe sur
le marché de la consommation.
Ça peut être un danger aussi
dans ces cas-là pour
une personne dans sa prise
de risques.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Un sujet délicat
pour les organisateurs
de ces événements.
♪ ♪ ♪
La consommation de drogues
est interdite, mais, malgré
les fouilles, c'est une réalité
dans le milieu de la musique
électronique.
NICOLAS COURNOYER, v.-p.,
Aff. publiques, Multicolore
- Ça existe, c'est une réalité.
Après qu'est-ce qu'on
fait, nous, pour être proactifs
et s'assurer que les gens ont
la meilleure expérience
possible.- Bien qu'ils collabort
avec le GRIP pour d'autres
services, les organisateurs de
Piknic Électronik sont réticents
à offrir un service d'analyseà .
- Il y a un paradoxe. Fait que,
on est pas contre la vertu,
on est pas contre le projet,
mais de dire qu'on fait ça,
on assume puis ça se fait,
alors que, techniquement,
tout ça est illégal.
réal,
pas d'hésitation.
L'analyse de substances
sera offerte par le GRIP
sur le site-même du festival,
lanade du stade
Olympique.
SIMON GAMACHE, directeur
général, Fierté Montréal
- Pendant la pandémie, surtout
dans lesIA+,
ça a été difficile, les gens
ont été isolés. On parle de
personnes marginalisées qui ont
été plus isolées que jamais
et, oui, de la
consommation, plein de... plein
- La santé publique de Montréal
rapporte une hausse des surdoses
dans la dernière année.
Mais impossible de comptabiliser
les événements reliés uniquement
aux événements festifs
à Montréal.
La crainte du fentanyl
est toujours présente.
STÉPHANE SMITH, Urgences-Santé
- On ass
le fentanyl à des drogues de rue
ou aux itinérants, mais,
maintenant, on voit cette
drogue-là beaucoup plus chez
Monsieurout-le-Monde,
qu'on n'aurait pas pensé
qu'ils en auraient consommé.
Dre MARIE-EVE MORIN, cofond.,
projet Caméléon, médecin de fam.
pas une clientèle
opiomane tellement dans
les festivals de musique
électronique. C'est vraiment
plus une clientèle festive,donc:
cocaïne, speed, métamphétamine,
beaucoup de MDMA.
- Depuis 2017, la docteure
Marie-Eve Morin intervient
dans les festivals avec
l'organisme projet Caméléon.
- Fait que c'est ça qu'on
cherche.
- L'analyse de drogue se fait
par colorimétrie, une technique
moins coûteuse, mais moins
précise que le spectromètre.
Cette année, son équipe
a reçu l'aval du ministère
de la Santé et des Services
sociaux du Québec pour effectuee
substance au festival Éclipse,
en Outaouais.
- Le "drug testing
ça augmente pas la consommation,
ça la diminue. Parce que,
quand on a une personne
devant nous qui vient d'acheter
10 "speetons,tons,tons,tons,ton,
puis qui nous fait analyser ça
puis qu'on dit : "Écoute,
on pense qu'il y a des traces
de fentanyl là-dedans".
as.
- L'analyse de substances
devient ainsi une façon
d'établir un dialogue
avec la personne qui consomme.us
de la Colombie-Britannique,
où l'analyse de substance
en festival se fait déjà
depuis plusieurs années.Une manr
les mauvaises surprises
et de réduire les risques
de surdoses.
- (Win Butler): Merci, Montréal.
(acclamation de la foule)
Here we
One, two. Ouh!